the show is anything but normal when tom
curran joins us and he's
with us now on loan from nbc sports
boston
what's been the fallout tom locally
of the comments last week from owner
robert kraft where he was very candid
about draft problems that the team has
had in recent years and the current
struggles of the franchise what's been
the reaction to that
i think it was eye-widening for people
to hear robert kraft specifically
criticize bill belichick in no uncertain
terms
you know actually i say that he didn't
he criticized the performance of the
team
in certainly ways that he is entitled to
haven't drafted well no lie there can't
make all our moves
in free agency we have to draft better
no eyes there
um i just think that for a team that is
so cloistered and tight-lipped
it was interesting to hear robert kraft
speak so frankly
look he's 80. belichick 69
and i think those things have to enter
into the conversation all due respect to
what he's done
but we're not sitting around and
thinking that seven nine eight and eight
and ten and six are okay
given what we do and how good builders
so then what is the remedy for that this
year do you see the patriots
making a move in the first round to
maybe trade up
miles like don i i think that mike
lombardi
was very good on it i thought on his
podcast on the ring of the uh
gm shuffle podcast he talked about the
fact that
there are going to be grades on players
and once you get past those first three
quarterbacks who are definitely going to
go
then you're talking about numbers are
the grades on
matt jones or trey lance going to have
them
as what would be top 10 quarterbacks in
the league and that's how
mike lombardi was defining it when you
get to that point
and probably not my guess is all those
quarterbacks and all those wide
receivers
and kyle pitt's thrown in and the tackle
here and there are going to drive down
the board a really good player
who's probably going to have better
relevance to the patriots more quickly
than a projected quarterback and that to
me is the interesting shuffle mike when
you think about it
what's better the best linebacker
or the developmental quarterback with
high upside and then you have to add in
88 year old
80 year old owner 69 year old kent coach
you almost made robert kraft 88 and let
me just correct you because he's not
quite
80 yet he's not 80 until june
and i suspect i suspect if i were
pushing a milestone birthday and someone
was trying to give me that next number
before
i was there i wouldn't be happy about it
let me enjoy
the last two months of being 79
please that would be my confirm and we
also want to be accurate here miles who
is
facing down 30 at some point between now
and october the 8th
can confirm that um what do you think
the chances are
though let's say they stay put at 15.
let's say one of these guys sneaks
through
a justin field somehow sneaks through i
i haven't taken a first round
quarterback since drew blood so number
one overall in 1993
one reason is they went 20 years with
tom brady and there was no reason to but
would it be a temptation to to get that
guy that you could make
the next 10 15-year quarterback of the
team if
if he happens to slip through the cracks
and be there when the patriots are on
the clock
it has to be you know and that's the
interesting thing we do talk about
grades
you know the patriots might have been
married to grades in 2018 they drafted
sony michelle
31 at 32 lamar jackson goes sonny
michelle helped them win a super bowl in
2018
but has been probably at best a
part-time but somewhat productive
running back since
lamar jackson's got an mvp so would they
be better off if they take him lamar
jackson or did they have a great look
he's a third round kick if he's there
we'll take him then but he's great isn't
high enough so
what will the persuasiveness of a fields
be
or a trade lance be if he's still
sitting there if they're still sitting
there
at 15 what's the upside how quickly can
they help you win
what's interesting guys is the floor the
patriots operate on because bill
belichick is their head coach
they have the worst roster in football
offensively last year if you ask
me decent offensive line to better
offensive line
okay running backs but embarrassingly
bad
at the wide receiver in tight end
positions
a non-starter as a passer in cam newton
and they still won seven games
they so their floor is so high that to
upgrade those positions that were
embarrassing last year
make them what nine and seven well nine
and
eight ten and seven hard to get used to
yeah
i know so that that to me becomes the
question do you want to get micah
parsons do you want to get the successor
to
staphon gilmore and take caleb farley or
if he's still sitting there do you want
to take the left tackle the future
um or do you want to try and get a
quarterback who may or may not be ready
in two or three years because wow you
need a quarterback well but
when you look at the division though and
you see that buffalo's got josh allen
miami you know they've got to attack
available jury's still out on him
jets are going to get zach wilson i
think we all know that and the jury will
still be out on him
does that maybe create some urgency to
make sure that they have their
quarterback
maybe not just of the future but even of
the present on the roster
it's so fair it's a fair question but
here's what i would say
how many darts did the bills have to
throw with the board in the top
five for top 10 to get the guy and the
patriots are still at 15. the jets are
going to throw a second dart
in three years at a top five tick miami
we know the lydney accord have actually
started there so
it's it's hard to predict it's it's how
well do you think freight lance
and justin fields and or mack jones are
going to perform if he's the guy that's
that slips which i think he should i
think he's probably going to have this
the lowest ceiling of the group highest
or lower ceiling
um which one do you want which one do
you want
to say okay that guy is going to be our
future here if he's not spectacular i
mean
to me i look at matt jones to say best
case scenario kirk cousins worst case
colt mccoy
tom jimmy garoppolo's name has been in
circulation the past two weeks after the
49ers move up from 12 to 3 to draft a
quarterback it's clear that's what
they're doing it's clear jimmy
garoppolo's not in their plans it's
clear the 49ers are trying to posture
for a trade i don't think anyone wants
to touch a 25 million dollar
compensation package
for jimmy garoppolo could be a trent
brown type of a deal where
jimmy takes less reasonable draft pick
along those lines
could the patriots be in play for
something like that with jimmy g
for significantly less than 25 million
mid to late round pick to the 49ers add
him to the mix i know you believe that
in the past
do you see it happening now that it's
clear he's not going to be with the
49ers over the long haul
in conversations i've had in order to
trade for jimmy garoppolo
and bring him on and get him to accept a
pay cut that's almost a non-starter
from what i understand because if you're
going to trade for him you're saying
okay we just added all these pieces
we want you to be our trigger man and
why don't you take a pay cut too
because 25 million for a player that
you're going to
trade for is not insane the way the
quarterback prices have risen
so you can't bring him in and say why
don't you play for 18 or 20
redo your contract i just don't think
it's something that would be as
appealing to him so you're gonna have to
wait for him to get cut
and then be the highest bidder and then
figure it out to me the simpler way to
do it was simply
almost an east coast version of jimmy
garoppolo
is to go get teddy bridgewater send a
fourth round pick
to the carolina panthers maybe even a
third and you bring on a guy who's eight
million dollars less
who's just as accurate who may be just
about as durable
is as good a leader it's the same guy i
mean
am i nuts on that everybody i mentioned
it too says yeah kind of
well i i mean i i covered the first part
of teddy bridgewater season with the
panthers last year and i
i mean i just wasn't very impressed with
the way that he played i mean i know
that he's a guy that has won games but
he's also someone who doesn't seem to be
able to necessarily elevate you past
the the point of diminishing returns uh
if that makes any sense
it does it's like ten and two he's got
his hands at ten and two is he going to
uh make yes is he gonna lift all votes
i don't know if jimmy does cam newton
certainly doesn't
jared spit him may not but there's that
yeah you're right
miles who lifts all boats how many guys
do that mike
well speaking of guys lifting boats the
question is how many boats are going to
be in the water julian edelman there's a
report that
it's doubtful he'll be able to play the
entire 2021 season you know edelman well
where do things stand currently with
his health and and his ability and is
there
some flicker at the core of this where
edelman's trying to finagle a path to
tampa bay in a reunion with tommy and
gronk
from the people i've spoken to my
understanding is that first health-wise
the procedure that he had done last year
was really to get him back to where he
was in
august he was so battered in 2019
shoulder knee ribs um
that he came off the field that year
really diminished
his knee never really healed fully and
then it worsened during the year when he
had
a procedure done during the year was to
bring him back to where he was at the
start it didn't fix everything
so it's more about take the field hope
and see how it goes so the report i
think was from karen to region that
there's doubt that he'll play every game
it's
certainly i think that we would all take
the under on
17 games for julian edelman but will he
still have value yes
and one interesting thing about edelman
in contrast to an amendola or a gronk or
a brady is that
he kind of does leave patriots
silver blue whatever it is so
he might not want to go anywhere else i
think that he has that
affection affinity and loyalty to bill
belichick
that those other guys were able to get
out of their systems put it that way
that is the one thing i wanted to ask
you about edelman is just where do you
put him
in terms of importance as a wide
receiver in patriots history because he
seems like he should be up there
yeah i mean that the the mount rushmore
painting its wide receivers would be
i think certainly stanley morgan from
the 70s and 80s edelman
and then i guess you would say moss i
might i hate to miss somebody else but
moss and and i guess dion branch
that's that's it and edelman's certainly
there too edelman is a punt returner
look edelman wins three super bowls
while he's here he helps throw them to
a win in 2014 over the ravens um
he's the mvp of the super bowl win over
the rams
he he makes the ridiculous catch against
the falcons
i think he's probably and welker should
be included in that too
but i think he's probably the best wide
receiver in terms of production
performance and big game moments in
patriots history
no chad jackson where's chad jackson on
that list but there really is
a long list of failures at the receiver
position and that takes me to my last
question for you tom
how surprised were you by the fact that
somebody's blabbing whether it's someone
who's there or someone who's no longer
there the albert breer report that bill
belichick went off the board
to pick and kill harry scouts had aj
brown debo samuel ranked higher
belichick goes alone
harry's a bust the other two are pretty
good
usually that's the kind of stuff that
doesn't make its way
to the media surprised it did
not entirely just because of the
intimations
i've heard over the years and from
different player
people in the organization not players
necessarily but look in the end it's
acknowledged
that bill for whatever his salary is it
was banded about that it might be more
than 20 million dollars
earlier this year um
that he has final say and final say does
not
include talking to area scouts does not
include talking to you know the college
scouting director necessarily it's bill
it's ernie adams
it's nick casario and people who grew up
at belichick's elbow
or right hand don't necessarily say bill
this is the wrong call
what's interesting is though when you
watch the video from the war room
with nikhil harry being selected
belichick stares and stares and stares
at the board and he has nick casario
saying to him
terry it's harry here bill it's harry
so i don't know i mean someone
unveiled the the process to get to harry
um but it was i i did see your sleuthing
i know that that goes against all the
unwrittens but it is something we always
do in the media where'd that come from
and i think that's you're probably
exactly right
well and look the reason i believed what
i believe is because if you look between
the lines last week to what robert kraft
said the guy who's not there anymore who
was there last year
a potential target for the criticism
that robert kraft has levied on the
draft process on that note we will bid
farewell and say thank you to tom kern
of nbc sports boston
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports